[Musica]
[Applauso]
buonasera a tutti io sono emanuele
ho 22 anni e oltre ad essere un atleta
di scherma paralimpica
studio ingegneria dell'automazione che
in sostanza riguarda tutto il mondo
delle protesi e dei robot suono il
pianoforte e io riesco a fare una cosa
che pochissime persone possono fare
ovvero questa
è infatti come potete vedere o una
bellissima protesi che tra l'altro gli
ho dato il nome carpet e infatti è da
quando ho dieci anni che io utilizzo una
protesi e da quando ne 8 che sono
amputato
sono stato amputato in seguito ad una
rarissima malformazione vascolare ha
avuto solamente alla gamba destra sin
dalla nascita inizialmente tale
malformazione facciamo sì che il sangue
circolasse veramente male nella gamba
quindi dapprima si gonfiarono tutti i
vasi sanguigni poi di conseguenza si
gonfiò tutta la gamba come fate potete
vedere nella foto io qui avevo 5 anni e
già si può vedere che la gamba destra
era molto più grossa rispetto alla
sinistra
come se non bastasse quella grossezza
faceva sì che la gamma fosse molto più
delicata perciò bastava cose come una
botta così
bastava chimici tasse o anche che ci
fosse una giornata troppo calda che
incominciamo sanguinare e potevo perdere
sangue ovunque poteva cadere al
ristorante a scuola mentre dormiva
ovunque e per tutti quegli anni i miei
genitori assieme ai per dottori
instancabilmente cercano un modo per
salvarmi la gambale provarono davvero
tutte senza mai riuscirci senza mai
salvarla davvero ed è curioso pensare
che io per tutti quegli anni non abbia
avuto minimamente un piano b ovvero che
l'unico piano lui obiettivo era quello
di sopravvivere
quindi noi aspettavamo
tanto il fatto che ci arrivasse un piano
b andrà bene qualsiasi cosa pur di
uscire da quella situazione
poi un giorno
nel 2007
i dottori che mi seguivano mi proposero
un ultimo rischiosissimo tentativo
l'amputazione e il problema è che nei
dottori né tantomeno i miei genitori
potevano esser sicuri del buon esito di
tale operazione
ed è proprio per questo motivo che
lasciarono a me la scelta finale
dell'amputazione
ovvero volevano che fossi io otto anni a
scegliere se sarà imputato o no
ed è anche di primo impatto può essere
impossibile anche solo immaginare con
bambino di 8 anni potesse comprendere a
tutta quella situazione soprattutto
quella scelta così difficile
ma vi assicuro che gli otto anni me ne
accorgevo bene
nonostante per tutto quel tempo la mia
famiglia ovvero le mie sorelle
ai miei genitori
fossero sempre sorridenti e avessero
sempre in testa un'unica parola che era
resilienza
nonostante questo
gli stanno sempre peggio
e perciò non ce la facevo più a perdere
tutto quel sangue non ce la facevo più a
soffrire così tanto a rischiare la vita
ogni giorno
non ce la facevo più a vedere la mia
famiglia soffrire così tanto per me io
non lo star male non voglio pensare alla
gamma volevo giocare volevo stare con
gli amici a scuola e dopo averle provate
tutte veramente tutti di ogni per ben
otto anni
alla fine l'unica possibilità di
cambiare la mia situazione
anche strumenti di sperare di
migliorarla è andato dall'amputazione
perché quando in testa noi abbiamo un
obiettivo che vogliamo raggiungere a
qualunque costo di conseguenza le scelte
che facciamo diventano tutte più chiare
più nitide e bono tutte verso con
l'unico obiettivo ed esattamente quello
che pensa io otto anni e fu così che
pronuncia il fatidico si amputa temi
perché purtroppo di solito si considera
il piano b come o in generale una
alternativa
come
quella di minor importanza quella dire
massì dai dopo tutto questo tempo
lo faccio comunque quel percorso da
intraprendere nel caso il nostro
percorso principale non sa più possibile
bene per me è stato è l'esatto opposto
ovvero che a me il piano b è stata
proprio l'alternativa che mi ha salvato
mi ha salvato la vita ed è proprio per
questo motivo che io sono rinato
l'amputazione mi ha permesso di iniziare
una vita completamente nuova e io
tutt'oggi confermo che sono nato due
volte proprio per questo
in ogni caso non c'è nessuna legge al
mondo per poter affermare con certezza
che il piano b sia sicuramente più
facile di quello
perché per me non è stato anzi pensate
che i mesi subito successivi
l'amputazione per me furono ancora
peggio perché avevo così tanta difficile
riabilitazione poi e abituarmi stare in
piedi i continui interventi sul dopo
fecero pensare a tutto tranne che alla
soluzione definitiva
ma era solamente l'ultima fatica da a
cui resistere e infatti da lì poi in cui
ci hai vivere per davvero
perciò mai sottovalutare i piani b
perché possa esser quelli che vi
salveranno la vita dopo una decisione
difficile magari
inoltre
avere un piano b è sinonimo di grande
elasticità mentale ovvero di saper
cambiare prontamente davanti agli
previsti della vita perché nessuno sa
quello che ci capiterà in futuro
nel 2007 io rischiavo la vita ogni
giorno e dottori mi davano pochissimi
anni di vita ancora poi due settimane
dopo venne amputato ne uscì e ora
quest'estate parteciperò alla mia
seconda parla in viale
qui vedete mai sottovalutare le
alternative ma sempre considerare tutto
ovviamente impegnarsi nel nostro
percorso principale ma quando quello non
è più possibile allora cambiare è
necessario
inoltre la cosa interessante
è che io faccio uno sport che schiera
uno sport stupendo che mi obbliga ad
essere così ovvero quando io sono lì che
tiro come avversario una certa azione
che faccio per cercare di toccarlo e
quindi di far punto toccarli con la mia
arma da scherma se la esegue med secondo
prima o mezzo secondo dopo il fatto
rispetto a quando la deve seguire la
colazione sbagliata non va più bene e il
mio versario mi tocca appunto
quindi io lì nella scherma sono
obbligato a cambiare continuamente la
mia strategia il mio percorso è
necessario ad ogni alzato che faccio per
vincere contro il mio avversario e
questo mio essere così diciamo
malleabile nell'ambito sportivo
mi ha poi permesso di esserlo anche
nella vita di tutti i giorni
perché infatti l'anno scorso arrivò del
copit intera pandemia quando viene a
sapere del posticipo della paralimpiade
il giorno stesso in cui viene a sapere
fuin tristissimo perché non vedevo l'ora
di andarlo a fare
poi però pensai subito a come utilizzare
tutto quel tempo guadagnato perché io
questo bruttissimo vizio o perché in
tutto quello che mi accade
cerco sempre di vedere la parte positiva
cerco sempre di vedere le opportunità
che la vita mi dà non quello che mi
toglie e così io capii che tutto il
tempo che avevo tre ditte guadagnato
anziché stare tutto il giorno sul
telefono o tutto il giorno davanti alla
tv dedicare tantissimo tempo
all'università allo studio ed è quello
che feci io già dal mattino dopo seguivi
corsi della mia università invito
lezione e questo io cambiare così
rapidamente mi ha permesso di recuperare
tantissimi esami all'università che per
via della scherma avevo dovuto lasciare
indietro purtroppo perché io
tutt'oggi sento come una sorta di
corrente che è in circolo dall'anno
scorso ma corrente di pessimismo di
negatività ma io fate conto mila maggio
in questo modo come un fiume in piena
che travolge tutto lungo il suo percorso
bene un film e di pessimismo di
negatività
di
speranza perduta anche di perdita di
ideali dire mai e cosa ci sto a fare qua
qual è il mio vero obiettivo
questo l'ho visto perché molto spesso mi
è capitato personalmente di essere
travolto da tale corrente oppure perché
dei miei compagni degli amici tutt'oggi
sono lì che vagano immersi in questa
corrente non sanno come uscirne
invece noi abbiamo il dovere di uscirne
non lasciarci trasportare da essa perché
se così fosse non avremmo più controllo
del controllo della nostra vita
sarebbe lei sarebbe tale corrente di
pessimismo a decidere per noi è
sicuramente non ci porterà a realizzare
i nostri sogni a raggiungere nostri
obiettivi sicuramente
perciò in qualunque modo dovrà cercare
degli appigli degli aggrappi al quale
grazie ai quali tener duro ancora perché
è questa se questa situazione non sarà
eterna non lo sarà devo resistere per
ciò che mi vuoi scoprire la preziosità
delle piccole cose
di gioire tre piccole cose forse di
piccoli obiettivi da raggiungere
quotidianamente
perché solo grazie a quelli potremo
uscirne
c'è una parola che mi sta molto a cuore
ovvero che
lamentarsi
la lamentela perché è proprio per tale
parola che io ho iniziato l'università
nel senso che quando ancora ero alle
superiori e fantasticavo su diversi tipi
di protesi super futuristiche insomma
delle cose assurde tipo da film
però ero ha rattristato da vedere che
nella realtà tutto quello di cui parlavo
ancora non esisteva e così anziché stare
ad aspettare o ancora peggio aspettare
lamentandomi
che tutto quello che immaginavo ancora
non esistesse mi disse beh io no le
possibilità si allora perché non dovrei
fare la mia parte perché non dovrei
inventare io le protesi di cui parlo
sicuramente sarà difficile
però se io chiaro l'obiettivo dove
voglio arrivare non c'è nulla che può
fermare al limite mi possono rallentare
ma mai fermare del tutto
perché davanti al pensiero di poter
creare protesi che possono migliorare la
mia vita o quella di persone amputate
o con qualunque situazione
non c'è fallimento design che tenga non
c'è fatica
tante volte mi capita di avere poca
voglia di studiare di fallire degli
esami
ma già io sono lì ci sono dopo per
studiare ancora di più ancora più
duramente per raggiungere i miei
obiettivi e questo è faticosa e molto
difficile molto difficile ma sappiamo
dove vogliamo arrivare
allora sappiamo anche come arrivarci
anche hotel e fatica
perciò se tra qualche anno vedrete un
tipo volare nel cielo con una gamba
all'ironman quello sarò io sappiatelo
anche se purtroppo non è non c'è ancora
tale livello di tecnologia a livello
protesico io comunque ho scoperto vari
modi per utilizzare l'area protesi per
esempio essa è un comodissimo
portaoggetti
oppure si può scrivere delle formule di
fisica come questa che vedete forme di
fisica che io ai superiori usai per
passare un compito che passa ovviamente
oppure poi salute il per giocare a
baseball con gli amici
può essere utile per allacciarsi le
scarpe comodissimo sant che piegarsi o
alzare le gambe to alzi il ginocchio si
è fa in un batter d'occhio
oppure nel caso in cui ti sia
dimenticata torta è un ottimo sostituto
per il tuo compleanno
finisco raccontandovi un episodio che mi
è successo diversi anni fa
io all'epoca ero in discoteca con alcuni
amici
dopo aver provato per tutta la sera a
conosce nuova ragazza ovviamente senza
successo
io mi guardai la gamba
e pensai
beh dai devo provarci vale la pena
provarci
perciò andai da una ragazza che ho visto
che mi piaceva e dopo essermi presentato
le feci guarda faccio una scommessa se
riesco a fare una cosa che nessuno qui
dentro riesce a fare tu mi dai un bacio
che lei era un po titubante perché
ovviamente uno sconosciuto via elitista
costa ex acna pensi però visto che era
anche incuriosita da quel modo così
diretto di fare mi rispose va bene
fammi vedere
io che come stasera ero col pantalone
lungo tre si fece questo
al che potrebbe potete immaginare che
era stupidità scioccata che non se non
so cosa dire al tennis io scusa se sei
rimasta così comunque se non ti basta
c'è anche il piede
e anche lei era forse un po confusa da
tutto questo fatto sta mascot mentre
estramente stupita fatto sta che mi
prese inizio a baciare e io che ero
sedicenne è l'unica cosa che uscì a
pensare fu sei grande e ce l'ho fatta ho
inventato un nuovo metodo per croce a
ragazze così quindi questo simpatico
esempio vecchio farvi capire che quello
che molte persone vedono come un difetto
con una mia caratteristica negativa per
ma in realtà il mio più grande pregio è
il mio orgoglio perché sì io sono
orgoglioso di essere imputato sono
orgoglioso di avere una protesi
ma cosa bella è che sono tutti diversi
ognuno di noi ha una caratteristica
particolare che gli altri non hanno e
che purtroppo ancora troppe persone
considera un difetto
io sono qui per dirle l'esatto opposto
che tutti noi ben qualcosa di speciale
magari ancora non ce ne abbiamo un conto
che neanche io capii subito l'utilità
della protesi
però conoscendoci lo possiamo scoprire
ma soprattutto se riusciamo a vedere una
via d'uscita doveva ufficialmente
provare rischiare sperimentare osare
perché questo modo possiamo trovare dei
nuovi stimoli che ci possano stimolare
per andare avanti
per scopi noi stessi il nostro vero
potenziale è difficile è stato molto
difficile anche uno che ho passato alla
gamba lo dimostra lo si può fare
e soprattutto se c'è una cosa che io ho
imparato da tutta da tutta la vita e che
non dobbiamo mai smettere di combattere
di lottare io ho combattuto contro la
malattia da bambino combatto ora quando
faccio scherma e combatto per
raggiungere gli obiettivi e per
realizzare i miei sogni
è difficile estramente difficile ma io
so che
combatterono a combattere perché a tutti
i costi voglio raggiungere quegli
obiettivi che mi sono posto e io non
sono né più né meno di tutti voi perciò
tutti lo possano fare basta solamente
capire che possiamo combattere che
possiamo non arrenderci mai anche se
difficile e soprattutto vorrei che fosse
chiaro che non è mai troppo presto
neanche troppo tardi per iniziare a
combattere per iniziare a vivere
c'è un'ultima cosa
salutandovi mi voglio raccomandare a voi
dicendovi che torna avanti
qualunque cosa facciate e ovunque
andrete mi raccomando siate sempre delle
persone
in gamba
[Musica]
grazie